what up guys welcome to reddit saturdays
got a special intro
for you courtesy of um our our ho
our big guy today brian rose a lot of
brian rose content
just to prepare you so as tribute i
wrote a
a short little song for the channel
let's
put play the b let's do this drop the
beat
brian oh yeah oh yeah brian drop the b
brian oh there you go
okay i like it brian
welcome ready saturdays we're gonna have
a good time
looking at some schemes while they try
to sell us dreams now man i'm fine
leave your scam out the door we'll keep
laughing till we're bored then we'll do
it all again next
saturday
okay let's go to the board okay that was
nice for 10 seconds um what's up guys
welcome to the 10 million dollar studio
i won't
bore you i do like to play the keys
sometimes
but it's time for a reddit review i felt
like we had to reintroduce it because
every time i tell y'all i'm going to do
a bunch of reddit videos and i don't do
them
so i have to reintroduce the concept
where you guys submit stuff to my reddit
r copyzilla underscore gg and i get free
content out of it and i get a laugh at
it and you guys get your work featured
so i think it's a win
win what have you guys been up to what i
want to know
what i'm trying to figure out up first
even youtube
ain't what it used to be youtube someone
replied to my comment
thanks for your comment expert smith is
carefully
currently handling my crypto okay
that's enough and it's a scammer guys
i've like reported like 20 people
20 profiles of coffees that led to
youtube i don't know how many more i can
do waste so much of my time
youtube doesn't care they really don't
if you guys see those just do the report
feature
i do it every time let's see here oh
wait what
they're also actors that's a backstage
profile
is this real did brian rose hire out his
whole
i wouldn't be surprised honestly that
would make so much sense by the way
related to the brian rose content i
can't do brian rose videos anymore
because he he copyright strikes every
single one
it's absolutely insane i even posted
about
somebody else's coverage of brian i
reacted to it and he copyrighted that
so literally there's you can't talk
about this guy he'll copyright claim
every single one of your videos
so sorry about no brian rose content
recently he's just he's
a total yeah anti-free speech when it
comes to that
the photo of the london real party tells
you everything you need to know about
brian's narcissistic personality
that's how every photo of brian it
probably is he's probably like get back
i need to be in the i need to be the
sitter focused oh my gosh how much do
you think it pisses him off when one of
his cameramen gets him out of focus for
like three seconds he probably
loses his mind dude brian drinks his own
urine twice
oh yeah i've seen this before this is
just mind-blowing
what is he doing
so it's a little salty this is
embarrassing i would never be seen in
daylight again
if i drink my own piss by the way i
don't know if you guys know this
i did place a whole bet on this on the
brian rose london election
i have big stakes riding on it now i've
decided that if brian rose wins
i will drink my own urine on camera
that's right and as i just told you if
that happens to me i'll never be seen
again i would never be caught dead in
public
after having a video of me online
drinking my own urine
like unless you have to like if you're a
bear grylls in the wild it's kind of
like badass
but if you're in your office peeing into
a cup
and drinking it purposely like i'm gonna
not have too much but i'm gonna have
enough
yours foaming and all that that's
disgusting
i have committed me and amish my co-host
on the trip
uh which you can go subscribe to that
channel we've committed to drinking our
own urine if brian rose wins you know
obviously i don't want him to win so i'm
endorsing count bin
face to run against him hopefully he can
beat sadiq khan as well
okay let's see next meme fake guru every
morning
let me finish my milk real quickly i
have to pass on
my knowledge to the world i swear dude
it's always like children
we've really gotten to that point all
these advisors like tick tock is just
getting life advice from 13 year olds
that's what it is it's a life advice
channel from 13 year olds
pbd memes anybody let's see here steven
keep it above the belt
amish this is the glasses
ninety percent of guys zilla
oh dude hey if you guys don't know
there's a call back to the
pb uh patrick by david debate we did on
the drip you can go watch it now
where things got out of hand towards the
end of the debate i told him you should
keep it above the belt
and he really pissed patrick vette david
off he got him really upset
are you like trying is your goal like
watch me get under his skin
next one the champ is here let's see
what this is about
pov you're a waiter and you ask patrick
bet david
super salad patrick bet david shares all
of homer's odyssey
iliad and the lord of the rings trilogy
story
yeah that's that's kind of true i mean i
witnessed it okay
the guy there's no simple questions
okay there's only stories long long
stories
guys guys i have a secret method that
will save you thousands of dollars
don't give them to scammers underneath
yeah
hey man it's a test in my comment
section i think i've said that before
if you get scammed by one of these
things you haven't learned your lesson
okay
it's like maybe i shouldn't be reporting
these maybe i should let them
proliferate
evidence 248 that grant cardone has
always been crazy
licking a 750 thousand 60 pound bar of
gold
what what'd you make a certain amount of
money like it's not about millions
millionaires are fine
multi-millionaires are fine when you get
to the billionaire stage you start to
lose like
it's not brain cells because these
people are often times very clever
or smart but they lose like this level
of
self-awareness or care about what other
people think because they're so rich
but i don't think that you should lose
all your self-awareness right like if
you lose a little bit of it that's fine
it makes you bolder when you lose
everything you become like this i mean
this is this is your
fate like here a little bit not too much
but a little bit what people think
cal finn faces released his manifesto on
instagram please like and share
guys please london will be renamed after
phoebe waller
c london bridge amherst smith bridge to
be repaired and named after
uh renamed wayne after the former look i
don't even know what this says but i'm
sure it's of substance
i support him and we will be having him
on the show two of the most popular
youtubers um
joking about the absurdity of pyramid
schemes made my day
knock knock it's me oh hello come here
what up
fake guru community is getting a lot of
recognition like anti-scammers
everybody's anti-scammer that's what i
realized everybody but the scammer this
is like
it's so funny because some issues you
know it's like polarizing whatever
with the scammer space it's like people
who are scamming people for money and
then like everybody else hates it
i like to buy three wishes oh it's a
sale
[ __ ] pyramid scheme for wishes
by now everyone's getting in on it he's
i'm german too
all right if you buy three wishes you
can give three wishes to your friends
and they can give three wishes to their
friends yes the package only costs nine
thousand
no it's amateur it would cost eight
thousand nine hundred ninety seven
dollars
it always ends at a seven baby that's
good stuff man jacksepticeye and
pewdiepie
given some love getting knowledge from
sifu ain't
is not as easy as you think it can cost
everything
i am your new sifu i will help you to
get successful and rich
but before that pay me 7.99 i know guys
how much you willing to pay to know
how to get rich are you willing to give
me your whole bank account pay me 7.99
and i will sell you summary of 25 ted
talks
fake guru knowledge dude that's true
it's like
hey you want to get regurgitated
self-help advice that everyone's been
saying forever
pay me 800 8.97 all right and then this
one message to all the haters from uncle
g
hey reddit grant cardone here i know
some of you've been wondering who is
this dude grant cardone that seems to be
everywhere from snapchat to youtube
to i hate how these marketers talk
nobody's been thinking that
nobody's been thinking man this guy i
see him remember only grant cardone
thinks he's everywhere that's the funny
thing about these guys they sell ads for
themselves constantly because they're
not everywhere and they need they have
to they can't get there organically
they're constantly shilling ads stuff
like that but grant cardone especially
has such a like
psychotic complex about this did you
guys see the uh jordan belfort grant
cardone interview i'll pull that up real
quick
literally this is one of my favorite
moments from that epic
i don't know if you want to call it
debate or just grant cardone um
arguing himself into the dirt about like
not no interest is interest or whatever
but uh there's a moment where you know
jordan belfort's asking about the 10x
conference
and grant cardone honestly believes in
his heart of hearts
that everyone knows about 10x everybody
knows about him because he's such a big
shot and this is like
the psychology of someone who would make
that video of like hey reddit i bet
you're wondering who i am
who's this guy you've been seeing
everywhere look at this look at this
psycho saying something right
how about the uh how about the 10x
conferences
what do you know about what have you
heard i don't know anything about it
please
i don't know anything about him buddy
how do you know how do you know to ask
about the test i see it
he can't believe it no seriously tell me
about the 10x conference i don't i don't
know about it i really don't
know nothing about it nothing okay i
want to ask you guys
look at this he he literally is in
disbelief this is the definition of an
ego that's too large
for any human being i don't know if they
taught that him that in scientology or
what but
it's just too much how many of you think
he's bullshitting right now
don't ask him i'm asking your viewers
dude i'm asking the viewers you're
missing the police i like telling the
truth of course i am
everybody knows it's about the 10x i
don't dude
that's who you're dealing with with
these figures that's the kind of uh
the egos you're playing with dude all
right i think that does it
it's pretty good uh memes today i'll
give it a 7 out of 10 honestly we've had
better we've had worse thank you for
submitting to the coffeezilla subreddit
i appreciate you
thank you for pumping the stock as usual
by liking and subscribing
and i'll see you guys next saturday with
another
wake up smell video coffee